the woman in me the autobiography
chronicling the life of teen pop
sensation Britney Spears sold 1.1
million copies in its first week on sale
in the United
States Spears Memoir which became a
bestseller even before its October 24th
release date sold 1.1 million copies in
all formats including sales of an audio
book narrated by actress Michelle
Williams the singer's autobiography
sheds light on Spear's relationship with
Justin Timberlake her public mental
breakdown and harrowing
conservatorship Spears skipped the
traditional promotional Circuit of
morning and late night shows ahead of
its
release still Spears joins a small
number of authors to have Memoirs hit
the 1 million sales Mark so
quickly the January release of Prince
Harry's spare which sold 1.6 million us
copies in its first week broke the
Guinness record for fastest selling
non-fiction book and is still the
bestselling book so far this year other
books to have hit the milestone in their
first week include Barack Obama's a
Promised Land Michelle Obama's becoming
and Donald Trump's niece Mary Trump's
too much and never
enough Britney Spears likely earned
between 12.5 million and $15 million for
the woman in me multiple news outlets
reported Gallery said the woman in me is
its fastest selling audio release of all
time Michelle Williams narration has
been widely acclaimed and floated as
potential Grammy fodder in the upcoming
award season Vanity Fair
suggested and US streams for Spears
music catalog increased 24% in the first
week her book was released NBC News
reported in 2021 Forbes estimated
Spear's net worth at $60
[Music]
million